sí pues es realmente lo que dice aquí la
gente en el centro de la ciudad de miami
es que las urnas que la gente ha hablado
el pueblo se ha pronunciado y que no hay
mucho más al margen de movimiento que el
donald trump puede efectuar todas las
medidas que quiera frente a las cortes
pero quién tiene la última palabra de
todos estos es el poder del pueblo que
ya ha hablado en todo eeuu en estas
elecciones presidenciales aquí la gente
continúa celebrando esas decisiones a
este resultado de estas elecciones que
joe biden es el presidente electo hay
muchísima gente concentrada allá en el
centro de la ciudad de miami apoyando al
joe biden ya el presidente electo y que
se va a convertir en el presidente
número 46 de eeuu pero como les digo no
hay prácticamente reacciones a esas
palabras de julián y en esta conferencia
y han dicho de nuevo que el pueblo ha
hablado y que en la decisión están en
los votos de la gente y le pregunto un
poco más porque sabemos que en miami hay
una gran presencia de latinos el estado
de florida lo ganó el presidente de
donald trump
pero el condado de miami dade donde
están las principales comunidades de
cubanos y de venezolanos de este estado
y de eeuu pues en este en este condado
ganó joe biden hasta el momento usted ha
encontrado reacciones opuestas personas
que están de parte de trump que piden
esta impugnación que están de acuerdo
con estas demandas pero al mismo tiempo
la celebración por joe biden o sólo hay
celebración en este momento
si de hecho a la una de la tarde hora de
miami se había convocado una protesta en
la ciudad de doral un lugar donde
predominantemente viven muchísimos de
los venezolanos partidarios de donald
trump se había convocado precisamente
esa marcha para denunciar que estas
elecciones habían sido un fraude el
mismo discurso que había utilizado el
presidente de donald tram a lo largo de
todos estos días cuando ya se iban
conociendo poco a poco los resultados y
esa marcha en principio sigue ahí en la
ciudad de doral un número de unos 100
automóviles están marchando por las
principales calles y bueno lo que piden
es eso qué
el apoyo de la corte suprema en todo
esto y un mensaje muy preocupante
también para algunos de ellos y es que
dicen que por alguna razón el presidente
de donald trump a nombró a tony barber
antes de estas elecciones y dicen que en
sus manos está que se acabe decidiendo
el futuro de esta nación unas palabras
realmente preocupantes por alguna parte
del electorado aquí en la ciudad de
miami
[Aplausos]